I'm looking at your stamp, the hunk over
your name and they'll, it looks like,
so it looks like it's Jean
was something, right? Well,
I don't know how to say your last name
right? I can't, I don't know
one of your 50 language.
I can't, I can't. Pretty good. I
can't spot the other character.
What is your choice? You know,
it's because it's kind of a old,
it's kind of an ancient calligraphy,
older calligraphy,
so it's way as in way phone,
like bravery or valor.
My father was,
he was a nationalist,
so it basically says my paternal
Haim and then national valor
national valor
optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought
to you by trunk club.
I hate shopping with a passion.
Going shopping for fun to me is like,
let's go do our taxes. I don't get
it. It's something that I have to do,
but I don't like it at
all and quite frankly,
I'm not good at it and I always end up
looking like I'm colorblind or homeless
or something like that.
So Roi really sucky and as a result
I decided to try trunk club and I,
I expected to dislike it quite frankly.
But here's how it works and here's why
I'm now a huge fan and just as a prelude,
the items that I kept from them,
I've had more compliments from random
women on like t shirts and shorts and
these funky green shoes
that I got than ever before,
which proves that I don't know
what I'm doing. And they do.
You go to trunk club.com forward slash
Tim, you answer a couple of questions,
then you get assigned a personal stylist.
So mine was Robin.
Then they send you a trunk full of
awesome stuff that they predicted you will
like and look good in based on
your sizes, preferences, et Cetera,
that they've covered in
this short phone call.
It was really short and to the point then
this trunk is delivered to your home.
It's free of charge both ways.
So you only pay for clothes that you keep.
If you keep none of them,
that's fine.
You mail the whole thing
back with a prepaid label.
They even include tape to shut the box
and you're good to go cost you nothing.
There's no ongoing subscription.
This is not a subscription service.
So only when you ask for a
trunk you will get a trunk.
And I expected to keep
maybe two items out of 18.
I didn't want a thousand
things sent to me,
so I got about eight things sent
to me and expect it to keep too,
because they give you a preview online
to show you what's coming and end up
keeping four. And I've been traveling with
those. I've a very minimalist luggage,
but I've been traveling for a couple of
weeks and I've brought everything with
me because it's been so multipurpose
and so well received. Uh,
it's kind of blowing my
mind quite frankly. So trunk
club.com forward slash Tim,
you get premium clothing,
great advice for zero work.
So it's a great and a,
the way they make money is really easy.
I mean they buy high quality clothing
at volume and they just charge you the
normal retail pricing. But obviously
they buy it at a cheaper price.
So there's no tricks, no hidden costs. Uh,
it's really easy to be the best dressed
man in the room or on the street.
So their entire styling services free
for now, like I mentioned, check it out,
trunk club.com forward slash Tim,
they also have club houses so you can
check that. I would just pretty cool.
So trunk club.com forward slash Tim and
you can get a trunk filled with sweet
clothing very easily.
That will make the ladies wants you
and make the men want to be you.
It is a good Roi. And for someone
who's always hated fashion,
now I can actually look fashionable
with next to no time expenditure.
So pretty sweet trunk club.com
forward slash Tim, check it out.
This podcast is brought
to you by Mizzen and main.
Don't worry about the spelling.
All you need to know is this.
I have organized my entire life around
avoiding fancy shirts because you have to
iron them. You sweat through
them, they smell really easily.
They're a pain in the ass.
Mizzen and main has given me
the only shirt that I need.
And what I mean by that,
and Kelly Starr at loves the shirts
as well, is that you can trick people.
They look really fancy so you can take
them out to nice dinners, whatever,
but they're made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So you can throw this thing into your
luggage in a heap or on your kitchen table
like I did recently, and then pull it out,
throw it on with no irony, no steaming,
no nothing.
Walk out and you could probably wear
this thing for a week straight or make it
your only dress shirt and take it on
trips for weeks at a time. Never wash it.
It will not smell.
You will not sweat through it.
You got to check these things out.
So go to four hour work,
week.com all spelled out,
four hour work,
week.com forward slash
shirts check it out,
four hour workweek.com forward slash
shirts and you'll see some of my favorite
gear, including the one shirt that
I've been traveling with. What's that?
My Little Munchkins.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show.
I've been waiting to record this intro
in this God damn garbage truck keeps
backing up.
So fuck it.
We're going to roll with it and
make that part of the ambiance.
The Tim Ferriss show is where I attempted
to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are chess prodigies,
hedge fund managers, athletes, artists,
comedians, celebrities, actors,
you name it, scientists.
We dig into everything.
And the reason is you find that
there are say morning routines.
There are meditative practices,
there are types of nutrition and training
that transferred across all of these
domains.
It's pretty amazing that you find
a common toolkit for excellence.
And in this episode we have Jimmy
Chin. And I remember at one point, uh,
Jimmy was kind of introduced to me
conceptually by someone who said if Chase
Jarvis, the world class
photographer and Laird Hamilton,
arguably the biggest big wave surfer
of all time, that's a biggest,
the best big wave surfer of all time
had a love child. It would be Jimmy.
And I was like, what the hell does
that mean? Well, Jimmy is an artist,
any professional athlete,
often at the same time as a nat Geo
National Geographic photographer,
he has participated in,
in documented breakthrough expeditions
around the planet from climbing first
ascents in the character rom to skiing
first descents in the Himalayas,
put another way.
He is one of the few people to both
climb Everest to the summit and then ski
down from the summit,
which is bonkers.
Most recently he filmed the directed an
incredible feature documentary called
Meru, m e R, U,
which is in theaters right now and one
the 2015 audience award at Sundance.
So what is Mary,
I'll put this in perspective for folks
in the high stakes game of big wall
climbing. The Shark's fin on mountain
marrow is, I suppose the ultimate prize.
Everest is a cakewalk by comparison,
sitting at the headwaters of the
Ganges River in northern India,
the shark's fin has seen more failed
attempts by elite climbing teams.
These are the best of the best over the
past 30 years than any other ascent in
the Himalayas or the
[inaudible] as they say.
And this movie is a story of one
group's journey to conquer it.
And, uh, there are many mishaps
along the way and it's a,
it's a white knuckle quest of friendship,
sacrifice, hope and obsession.
How the hell Jimmy captured it on film
while simultaneously risking his life is
impossible for me to fathom,
but we dig into it.
So in this episode of the podcast,
we talked about his origins training,
nutrition gear, and tackling
mirror, of course, uh,
which just really blows my mind
and I don't say that lightly.
So suffice to say, if you want to
benevolent kick at the ass, go see marrow.
That's your assignment.
I saw it with my family and uh,
for probably 15 minutes afterwards,
all they could say was, Whoa, whoa.
Over and over again. My
refrain was holy shit, under my
breath, muttering, you know,
20 times every hour or [inaudible].
It's really mind boggling, which Jimmy
pulls off. It's amazing, terrifying, and,
and awe inspiring and
inspiring at the same time.
So that further ado,
please enjoy my conversation
with the incredible Jimmy Chin.
Jimmy, welcome to the show.
Thank you. Nice to be here. It's,
it's really been an interview that I've
struggled with how to tackle because
when I watched is it Meru or Maru,
I don't know how to emphasize the
name of this. I say marrow marrow.
So it was basically 90 minutes of saying,
oh my fucking God. Oh my fucking God.
Oh my fucking God. So I feel like, uh,
most of the questions that I would have
formulated during that time might've
been hijacked,
but we're going to of course talk
about that and many other things.
But when you are asked by people, what
do you do, how do you answer that?
Because you have been described by
a friend of mine as, as the love.
If there were
one of Laird Hamilton and Chase Jarvis,
which I thought was hilarious since, uh,
both have been on,
both have been on the podcast,
both Amazing World Class Performers
in surfing with layered in many other
things.
And then photography with chase.
And I don't want the image in my head
of them actually doing anything sexual.
But how do you answer the question?
What do you do? Because you do so much.
Yeah, sorry, I was picturing
something terrifying actually. But
um, I feel like chase would, would
really get the worst end of that.
It'd be, um, you know,
that's a question I get
asked often and it's,
you know, it's kind of amazing
that I still don't have a
very good answer for it.
I generally break it down into three
pieces. I'm a professional athlete,
I am a photographer and I'm a film
maker and that's kind of divided by,
you know, my sources of
income. So I guess that's,
that's the best way that
I can describe what I do.
And an athlete kind of entails
everything from corporate speaking to,
you know, endorsement of
product or a brand ambassador,
or working on rd and d
with designers on jackets,
you know,
so they kind of spread through
a lot of different areas.
When I say athlete and the photographer
is both commercial and editorial work
and filmmakers kind of the same, you
know, documentary filmmaking and,
and commercial work as well.
It not for those people who may not
be familiar with your work, what,
what would the,
the Jimmy Chin highlight reel look like
when you're introduced by a friend at a
party who's had a couple of drinks,
and so it was very
enthusiastic when they want,
when they want to really catch
someone's attention with some of your
accomplishments. What are the
things that they throw out? I'd say,
Oh wow. I mean, you
mean flattering ones or.